[Music]
from the moment were born life changes
pretty quickly we go through several
different phases of our lives there was
a time when our biggest concern was
making friends at school how hard that
was getting bullied or picked on trying
to fit in be part of the cool crowd
remember when you first got your
driver's license you went to the movies
by yourself and nobody dropped you off
how about the first speeding ticket
[Music]
remember your girlfriend your first love
you went on your first date where your
mom didn't have to accompany you and
embarrass you in front of girl you're
trying to impress but remember that warm
fuzzy feeling of laughing together
maybe even stained up for a few hours
and you may not want to admit it but I
think we all had that one six hour
conversation with a special someone
remember graduation celebrating with
your friends how many of them are still
your friends how time flies
then the bigger decision start occurring
do I go to college do I get a job the
real world veterans and you start your
first day of work
[Music]
you and the lady are getting serious you
propose you get married maybe buy your
first home and you think you're living
the American dream the place where
you're working at it's starting to feel
like home maybe you feel the sense of
accomplishment by getting promoted and
getting a raise and the time came when
you and your spouse decided to start a
family or maybe your first attempt you
could turn for the worse
[Music]
or maybe you do get to experience the
joy of your first son or daughter as you
hold them close to you you can't believe
what you have in front of you here -
baby crying you tell yourself this is
yours this is mine the start of a family
legacy and sometimes it's not as easy as
we thought it'd be your kids grow up
right in front of you saying the
sweetest things from I love you daddy or
I love you mommy I don't know when I
give you a big hug but raising kids is
kind of like a roller coaster right
wound sugary one moment you can have a
special experience where your kid comes
home showing you a drawing she's done
saying this is our family and another
day they can run up to you with a gift
in their diapers but it's okay because
it's our kid on another vacation they're
playing t-ball and they get their first
hit and we're so proud of them our kids
have so much control over us don't think
how magical of a time that is then all
of a sudden life just happens maybe
things are going good and just like that
you lose a loved one
maybe your father or your mother it
could even be more sudden like a sister
or brother and you get that phone call
everybody goes through challenges maybe
you start feeling the emptiness are
being laid off we're being stuck at a
job you cannot grow maybe you recently
took a pay cut and you're close to
losing your home
[Music]
you're surrounded and dead and you feel
there is no end in sight
[Music]
but we all go through that some point
it's an inevitable part of life one day
you wake up and go to the restroom and
you look into the mirror and ask
yourself how did 35 years go by so
quickly and I think it's in these
moments that we must unlearn the
misconception that the world has
conditioned us to believe
[Music]
you